par contre les c'est nous qui paye c'est
à dire que je veux d'abord
voilà c'est pas direct on se maquille
ses rôles où il faut que ce soit un peu
voilà je venais ont peu de la jirs a dit
c'est toi la metteuse en scène c'est toi
qui fais aucun de toi tu s'il te plaît
ton 32 d'entre nous ont des desseins
allez c'est pas y aller c'est par
d'étaler sa qui pointe la gamme de toi
calme-toi réellement
atteinte est
inquiète pas t'inquiète pas
alors mettez moi chacun ya un barbare
vous êtes au début on est témoin cette
[ __ ] de boue et
c'est à cet accueil sa thématique
des mois cette fuite on
vous fait connaissance dans la piscine
ce qu'il est courant
de voir cette musique m'est témoin notre
truc prendre de coups
[Rires]
alors points dans ça peut
pas recevable
attendez à tonnelle pour casser
l'ambiance fait rentrer danielle
rival
attention à lévis
ma mère elle fait rsa
c'est géraldine qui gère c'est la
méthode c'est la metteuse en scène c'est
la méthode ans et
sur la tête de ma mère
[Rires]
cioni
mais toi de noël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jerad je tiens à féliciter gérard femme
géraldine eux je double votre cash
aujourd'hui
c'était une telle idée bravo